we are asked what is the slope of the
line that contains these points so pause
this video and see if you can work
through this on your own before we do it
together all right now let's do it
together and let's just remind ourselves
what slope is slope is equal to change
in Y this is the Greek letter Delta it
looks like a triangle but it's shorthand
for a change in Y over change in X
sometimes you would see it written as y2
minus y1 over x2 minus x1 where you
could kind of view x1 y1 is the starting
point and why'd x2 y2 as the ending
point so let's just pick two pair two XY
pairs here and we can actually pick any
two if we can assume that this is
actually describing a line so we might
as well just pick the first two so let's
say that's our starting point and that's
our finishing point so what is our
change in X here so we're going from 2
to 3 so our change in X is equal to 3
minus 2 which is equal to 1 and you can
see that to go from 2 to 3 just adding 1
and what's our change in Y our change in
Y is our finishing Y 1 minus our
starting Y 4 which is equal to negative
3 and you could have you didn't even
have to do this math you would have been
able to see to go from 2 to 3 you added
1 and to go from 4 to 1 you have to
subtract 3 for there we have all the
information we need what is change in Y
over change in X well it's going to be
our change in Y is negative 3 and our
change in X is 1 so our slope is
negative 3 divided by 1 is negative 3
let's do another example here we are
asked what is the slope of the line that
contains these points so pause this
video and see if you can figure it out
or this is a pause the video again and
see if you can figure it out all right
so remember slope is equal to change in
Y over change in X and we should be able
to pick any two of these pairs in order
to figure that out if we assume that
this is indeed a line well just for
variety let's pick these middle two
pairs so what's our change in X to go
from 1 to 5 we added 4 and what's our
change in Y
from 7 to 13 we added six so our change
in Y is six when our change in X is four
and I got the signs right in both case
it's a positive act when x increases Y
increased as well so our slope is six
fourths and we could rewrite that if we
like both six and four divisible by two
so let me divide both the numerator and
the denominator by two and we get three
halves and we're done